in in venture capital in your day-to-day
life and i do it for so many years so
you can think okay maybe it's boring but
not because you get to see
so many different domains and you have
to
learn them first when you do the
diligence and then when you invest and
you're on the board of the companies
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc funded in silicon
valley
in partnership with lumitec and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford
she is one of israel's top investors
welcome mae rav weinrib
managing director of qualcomm ventures
europe and israel
meravi is the managing director of
qualcomm ventures in europe and israel
she has more than 20 years of venture
capital and high-tech experience
prior to joining qualcomm ventures she
was a director at intel capital and
before that a principal at pitango
venture capital
meirov holds a bsc in information
systems engineering from the technion
and an mba from insead france mirava is
also the founder is on the steering
committee of the women founder forum
an organization that encourages and
supports female tech entrepreneurs
merav weinrib thank you for joining me
on 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good thank you thanks for inviting
me uh
it is my honor to have you here where in
israel are you calling from right now
i mean even working from home for the
last uh
10 months i guess or a year wow so you
know i usually start with the fun fact
about the guests but this time i'll give
a fun fact
i went to school for seven years in evan
yehuda in the american international
school
seriously it's a beautiful school it is
my second home
back then and forever and i just love
every huda ishimoto whoever hasn't been
there is the best restaurant
to go to in the world
we're not here to talk about avenue
we're here to talk about your phenomenal
journey
and most recently now managing director
of qualcomm
ventures you were also at intel capital
you were at pitango you know all these
incredible places that you know one day
maybe i'll be fortunate to be a part of
one of them
and so i i'm excited to hear about your
experiences
and a little bit about your journey and
insights into the tech scene
very active with early stage ai based
companies
and very involved also with empowering
women in tech
and and i'm excited to hear about those
passions and where you've taken them
so take me all the way from the
beginning how do you even enter the
the investment world so um
when i graduated from my business school
at insead i was exposed to many of the
next positions i might have and i have
to say that
venture capital was one of the exciting
things i looked up to
um it took me some years because i
thought i need more business experience
so after instead i went to
some smaller companies and bigger
companies including
in blaze and congress but when there was
an opportunity at
pitango i i just jumped on it basically
and
joined pitango as a principal and from
then i'm from then
and there i'm uh i'm doing vc which is
something i really like so actually
although i i didn't realize it but
about a year or two years ago i spoke
with someone
and i actually uh headed there
all all the time i was excited about it
in converse my last position was in m a
which
is kind of the other side of vc very
similar
so so that was a good um
stepping stone towards uh vc and i do it
for the last 12 years as you said and
pitango
intel capital and then for the last six
years in
welcome ventures and i have to say that
i really like the job
i love that so take me back to your time
at insead and you're finishing business
school
and what is it about venture capital
that really attracts you it's
it's a it's an interesting attraction
it's not
you know the i think that if i would ask
a lot of people 10 or 15 years ago
you know not many people would say you
know venture capital is a passion before
they got introduced to the investment
world right i think it's
it's it's pretty interesting tell me a
little bit about you know your
entrance into it and and how and sort of
like what has really got you attracted
to venture capital so at a business
school
you get to study a lot of different
areas so you
you look at finance and product and
product positioning and strategy
and you look a little bit at m a and
strategies of bing
big companies and startups etc and and
and business school is all about
diversity and many things you do and
learn
and and this is a lot the same
so in in venture capital in your day to
day life and i do it for so many years
so
you can think okay maybe it's boring but
not because you get to see
so many different domains and you have
to
learn them first when you do the
diligence and then when you invest and
you're on the board of the companies
then during the diligence you have to
to understand people that's very
important if this
early stage entrepreneur will be then
the next
unicorn ceo or not but you have to
understand
product and technology and markets and
strategy and business so it's very
diversified and this is what i liked
about it and this is what i like about
it today
every day you do something different you
learn different things you're on
different boards with different
companies
and you meet you meet a very
extraordinary people they are founded i
think that if
if anyone even dares to take a look at
the list of companies that you've backed
or
are a board member of those are you know
incredible companies
various domains a lot of them are
leveraging you know
some incredible technology but but
really in their core they're they're all
solving different problems
that require different expertise and it
sounds to me that what you're describing
is this entrance to
you know you keep changing worlds
literally worlds of problems and
and different unique solutions for them
and that's that's part of what it gets
you excited right
right exactly so in the last year i've
done a cyber security investment
a digital health one and a 5g
investment all are very very different
and it's exciting to be on the boards of
those as well as my previous companies
obviously
tell me a little bit about specifically
the attraction to deep technology
companies so
all three that you mentioned now along
with this really impressive list of
other companies that you've
worked with in the past 12 years in your
careers venture capital
what they have in common is that they're
deep technology right it's not just
another
you know a group of people that say yeah
let's just use something existing and
just
try it in a new market it's really a
critical technology that is not
it's not easy to understand it's not
easy to implement why
why specifically go that route as an
investor
so first of all as qualcomm we kind of
uh
we're a technology company and qualcomm
is a deep technology company and it's
known for
uh as a technology leader it actually
invented many of the
technologies we're using today so as an
investor
from um from a technology company
obviously i'm looking for deep
technologies but i think that
if you look uh back um
technology solves a lot of real world
problems if i think um
the best and easiest uh example today is
one of my portfolio companies
title care in which i invested a year
ago
right now it's kind of obvious why but
historically you would need to go to a
doctor for a simple ear check or
eye check or throat check
with their technology and they they
invested a lot in the technology
actually
uh to be able to allow a person to check
his child without any
medical background and be able to to
diagnose all kinds of simple things and
now with covet it's kind of obvious why
go to the clinic
sit there with your child he might catch
some kind of other disease or right
covey
when you can do everything from home now
without the technology
this problem wouldn't have solved and
this is just one example
from my portfolio the rest is in cyber
obviously um you know you have to have
very strong technologies because cyber
always
every time you solve one issue another
comes up because the
hackers never rest in uh
in communication you know when
every time there's a new generation now
everybody talks about 5g but
uh you think why need a new generation
and then the next generation comes and
all these
amazing uh applications so in 5g we
would probably see more
vr and ar applications it can happen
without this underlying technology so
technology is underlying a lot of
revolutions in the world and and right
now with carved
i think it's always and we're we're not
using
zoom but uh zoom is one of well
convention's investment without zoom i
don't know how the world would have
looked in in kovi
so all this uh in covet i think that
technology really proved itself as
something that could really really help
and
change world worlds i don't i don't know
what
my kids would have done without zoom in
the last
year um and etc
so so there are a lot of other examples
i i often stop and think about what
would have happened if covet happened 10
years ago even
not even you know even five years ago
it's it's pretty mind-boggling
you know the timing and and the end of
pre also appreciating what we do have
and personally getting excited about
what's to come
and the acceleration and i'm thinking
you know yes it's it's
it's a horrible what what's happening
but i'm looking at digital health and
you mentioned that
one of your deals this year was a
digital health and i get so excited by
seeing so many incredible entrepreneurs
working on these
really meaningful problems and having
somebody to talk to because now you have
the regulators
that are stepping up and saying yes we
need it we actually don't have an
alternative so we welcome you
and we're willing to change processes to
make it happen a process that you know
many estimate would have taken a decade
if it weren't you know for for something
as substantial as code to happen and i
think that at the end
i'm just curious to read about the case
studies of the acceleration
from this time tell me a little bit
about your process as you're coming into
this to new technologies to new
entrepreneurs getting to know them
what what are some big blocks that are
occupying your mind
as you're in going through that that
process of figuring out is this a
is are these people that i want to
partner with
so so really you have the the first
uh 45 minutes to one hour uh meeting and
this is
and this is kind of uh i have to say if
you talk to entrepreneurs it's kind of
unfair but this first meeting usually
you would get the 45 now on zoom it's 45
minutes used to be an hour
you really need to understand as many
things as
as you can so people is the first one
uh but then
the technology two sides of it
how how uh how much it would change the
world in one
how how destructive it is but on the
other hand
if it's doable at all we met especially
as
a deep tech investor we're meeting some
science projects uh that can take
forever
there are some examples in in the world
of science projects that's still going
on
got a lot of funding but no product yet
so this is one thing you have to look at
um and then uh during this
first meeting i would want to understand
the
the size of the market the competitive
landscape
how disrupting it really is how easy it
is to
uh copy the technology this is in a lot
of cases
especially in consumer electronics you
have
uh really innovative products
but it would be very easy to to copy
them once
uh once they're there in the market then
that's really important
um i have to say that what i get most
fascinated by
and inspired by the work that you're
doing and a lot of other venture capital
investors
is this ability to come into a meeting
and to come into a place where
you know you have people working for
weeks and months iterating over it and
you have to make a decision
pretty quickly about whether you buy
into this not just idea but buy into
this team
incl in court with you know with their
technology with the market and it's
putting all those pieces together
sometimes in a market that
you're not an expert in but but having
that ability to to quickly absorb
information and to process it
obviously sometimes making mistakes
sometimes you know missing a deal or
taking a
deal that we shouldn't have but but
that's that's inspiring to me that's
because that's a true curiosity in my
book at least
yeah and maybe going to one of the tips
it's
based on several meetings i had in the
last weeks and and zoo makes it even
harder so as an entrepreneur you have
this 45
minutes to one hour and uh not only in
israel but especially in israel
you get less presentation skills than in
other geographies this is what i
experienced
so on one hand a good ceo
doesn't have this to be necessarily a
good presenter
but when we see him for an hour he has
you know he or she has to be excellent
in
in this 45 minutes really get
really get us to get the message and and
really be
uh concise and and get all the messages
we're looking for because we're looking
for so many things in this
hour right and in some cases i'm seeing
people that could be maybe good ceos
but didn't practice enough on the pitch
and then they're missing out big time
because we wouldn't
even get to the next phase now on one
hand you would say
it's not fair maybe they're good ceos
but the thing is
that if they failed to present to us
we always think okay what would be next
right what would be in the next vc
funding they would go to the
q1 us vcs and they have to be perfect
because this is what their
ones are looking for so maybe one tip
and it's very very uh relevant to
israeli founders really really learn
your pitch
go to practice it there are very many
people
who can help you practice it it's more
important
in some cases than the technology or
other things
i mean technology is important but you
can have a great
startup in a lousy pitch
and it's a pity that's the thing and
it's kind of not fair and i should be
looking
beyond the pitch but this is what i'm
getting in the first 45 minutes
and it's really really missing it what's
really missing
i think that what's so what's so
important about this that you're
articulating is that you
can spend weeks and months perfecting
this beautiful product this beautiful
technology but at the end
just like they're meeting in front of
you for 45 minutes tomorrow they're
going to be meeting with a vp rnd of
this company they want to sell to and
they get 45 minutes again
and it doesn't matter how good their
technology is if they're not able to
convey it
to the next investor in the series a or
series b or
that vp that they have to sell to so i i
take that to heart and i after this i'm
going to go back and
and and practice my own things because i
think that's completely relevant
i want to make sure we have enough time
to also talk about your your passions
and
one of those passions is also empowering
women in tech and and a lot of other
things that you're doing so i'd love to
hear a little bit about you
what really gets you excited in the
day-to-day why why are you excited about
working with other women
and what are you doing the tech scene so
so
um the female the female founders forum
is
uh um something i initiated with a
partner around five years ago
and uh in texas inequality between uh
women and women when it gets to founders
the women founders
when i started uh 10 or 12 years ago
out of the 300 companies we would meet
every year there would be maybe one or
two
female founders that was the ratio um
and then uh when we started the program
it was also like
you with uh women founders and um
many male even today actually
there's not too many women founded five
years ago
um my partner to the women founders
forums ivan and myself sat together we
thought that we need to do something
about it and we founded this uh
initiative it's a mentoring program for
uh women founders that already got the
sid round already got into
the startup scene already either raise
some funds or have a company
and we help them through the fundraising
because
although the end goal is to create a
large and successful company
you have to go through the a round in
most of the cases so and and
we're trying to to get them more tools
to be able to
to raise their next funding even but
by getting them to write mentors from
the vc community as well as mentors from
the
tech community and uh this is exciting
because
i like working with the women i always
liked working with women although
most of my life i worked mainly with men
because i did a career in that
uh this is exciting because it's in a
it's a revolution really because
it's really changing uh
the way women are perceived in in our
industry
because the the balance is slowly
changing really slowly but changing
um and it's a lot of fun because our
program
participants already raised more than
200 million dollars
we had one exit so we're seeing this uh
revolution what we're creating there's a
new generation of
uh female founders that are role models
to the next uh
generation of founders so there will be
more women that will start their own
startups and their quality will start
happening
so that's what we're aiming at that
that's amazing
thank you so much for coming thank you
for spending time i know how busy you
are
and um and i really do appreciate it so
thank you very very much i have one last
question
that i have to ask and i asked that for
everybody and i apologize in advance
that i didn't prepare you enough for
this
but i need three words that either you
would choose to describe yourself
or if i ask any of your portfolio
companies how would you describe
me rav wow that that's a tough one
so um so my first passion is people and
working with them
the second is uh technology and the
third i still need to think about
so in the next episode you're going to
give me the third one
thank you very very much i i i just love
seeing the work that you're doing and i
and and hopefully one day i get to pitch
to you myself
and and and get feedback from you sure
hopefully sooner than later
sure thanks thank you take care